in Julianne Moore's new movie Maggie's
plan her love life is complicated there
may be an opportunity to get the two of
you back together you want to make sure
you don't feel guilty so you're going to
manipulate us all but in real life
things couldn't be more different
the actress opened up to ET at the
film's New York premiere on Thursday
where she explained why she's thankful
she's not in the social media dating
pool these days I imagine thankfully I
do not have to imagine it because I've
been with the same man for 20 years so
so far so good
the Oscar winner and her husband Bart
have two kids Caleb and Liv Julianne
says they're excited to spend Mother's
Day together I am working on Mother's
Day but then I'm but hopefully not for
the entire day and then we're gonna go
and in keeping with the new trend of
inviting Oscar winners on carpool
karaoke Julianne certainly would be a
perfect fit good news she told ET she's
down I'm sure yeah sure
I mean Maggie's plan is in theaters May
20th